to get started with the cloud natural
language API for go you'll need a GCP
project which you can set up in the
console
in your project enabled the Google
natural language API for that project
then create a service account and
download the private key as Jason you
need these credentials to access Google
Cloud api's so keep them secure and out
of your code and public repos to access
the credentials from your project go to
the terminal and set an environment
variable to the path of your service
account now install the client library
if you use cloud shell in the console
you can skip this step since the
required dependencies are already
included make a new file or open an
existing file I'm using vs code but you
can use whatever IDE you prefer
import the Google cloud client library
as well as some other packages you need
then instantiate a language client
if there's an error in instantiating it
handle it for the purposes of this
example I'm just going to log it provide
some text to analyze I'm going to go
with the classic example here
call analyze sentiment passing the
context a document object
and the type of encoding
the document comprises a source of
content which in this case is the text
hello world and a type of content which
is plain text includes some error
handling again for now I'm just going to
log the error if there is no error the
analyze sentiment function returns an
analyze sentiment response analyze
sentiment response has three properties
document sentiment the overall sentiment
of the input document language which is
the language of the text and sentences
which is the sentiment for all the
sentences in the document in this
example I'm going to focus on document
sentiment log if the sentiment score is
positive or negative score is a
sentiment score between negative 1 for
negative sentiment and positive 1 for
positive sentiment okay go ahead and run
the code and there you go you just sent
your first request to the natural
language API but there's more that the
cloud natural language API can do like
analyzing syntax and annotating text to
find out more about the client libraries
consult natural language basics or work
through the sentiment analysis tutorial
check out the cloud documentation
[Music]